and as time was up and she turned in her
contracts final exam she realized she
was in the wrong class and she had done
the wrong final today we're talking
about real life law school horror
stories ooh scary
[Music]
hey legal eagles D James Stone here
teaching you how to think like a lawyer
so you can crush law school law school
can be a really scary place it's three
years long and in that time a lot can go
wrong so I thought I'd share some of the
scariest things that actually happened
to me in law school so let's dig into
some of these scary stories one of the
first things that happens when you get
to law school is that you are surrounded
by some of the smartest people you've
ever met in your entire life I don't
really care which law school it is
you're gonna be surrounded by a type
personalities and some of those people
are what are called Gunners Gunners are
the people that always raise their hand
they always seem to have the answer and
when you first get to law school they
can seem really intimidating because
people don't like to answer the
professor's questions so I had a few
Gunners in my class hopefully I was not
one of those Gunners even though I'd
liked to answer on occasion but there
was one particular gunner in my class
for the sake of an amenity let's call
him Alan Alan was hardcore he would
answer every professor's question he had
a background in mathematics and
philosophy so he was able to talk about
the philosophical underpinnings of
different legal doctrines he was able to
think logically and he always seemed to
have the answer so after your first
semester you are given a slip of paper
with your grades in it and I happen to
be sitting behind Alan in class in
between classes when we were getting our
grades for the first time basically you
open up a slip a
and that's your report card and I happen
to see that he got all C's his first
semester I was shocked I I had never
seen anything like it one of if not the
smartest person in class got all C's let
it be a lesson to you that just because
someone is very good in class and seems
to be one of the smartest people in the
room it doesn't mean they're gonna get
good grades in law school and this
person eventually became a friend of
mine but man it was it was quite a shock
to see that this person who seemed to
know all the answers got straight C's
his first semester another horror story
that happened to me relates to my mock
trial competition I was on the mock
trial team for all three years in law
school I was one of the best experiences
that I had
mock trial is where you pretend to be a
lawyer you conduct a trial and you are
scored by judges based on how well you
do it's just like mock trial in high
school and college and part of the mock
trial competition is traveling to
different cities well one of the
competitions was held in Las Vegas in
fact it was one of the national finals
for this particular mock trial
competition and after my team had done
their round and we had actually
conducted around in front of a real
judge who actually tried cases in Las
Vegas the mock trial judge started to
brag to my team and the other team about
what happened one night when a burglar
tried to break into his house so this
sitting judge regaled us for about 15
minutes about how an intruder tried to
break into his house and what he did
with this intruder well apparently to
hear this judge tell the tale he sat the
intruder down on a chair tied him up put
him in a small bathroom and then for the
next hour or two proceeded to threaten
him with a gun to his head
and told him never to come back to his
house I'm guessing that if that actually
happened that that burglar never burgled
that guy's house again and this is again
a sitting judge I don't know if that's a
true story or not this was Vegas after
all so I probably believe that this
judge is an insane person who threatened
a burglar with a firearm so that was
that was an interesting experience
another horror story that happened to me
was that when I was sitting for the
California Bar Exam it was at a hotel in
in West LA and not just in the regular
part of the hotel but three floors down
in the basement and this was a huge
cavern I mean there must have been five
hundred people at least sitting for this
exam and so on day one of the exam we
were into the second essay portion of
the bar exam and all of a sudden as what
happens in California everything started
to shake there was an earthquake I later
learned that it was over a 5.0 on the
Richter scale so it was enough to get
the chandeliers in in the basement to
swing back and forth and all of the
people who were not native Californians
hid under their desk and you know were
shaken literally and figuratively and
and they lost some crucial time on the
bar exam I am the rest of the native
Californians just simply couldn't be
bothered and carried along writing our
essays so I actually feel that that gave
me an advantage on the bar exam because
I think the people who from out of town
were for a little bit frazzled whereas
being a native Southern Californian it
was just a normal Tuesday afternoon for
me so so I give partial credit to the
earthquake for helping me pass the
California Bar Exam another horror story
that happened to me was that my computer
crashed
right before finals so this was over 11
or 12 years ago so this is back in the
day when computers didn't have
solid-state hard drives and Dropbox and
Google Drive did not exist so I was
relying on the files that were
physically residing on my computer and
my hard drive just stopped working there
were clear signs that something was
going wrong so I had the the wherewithal
to transfer some of these these files to
I don't know a floppy disk or a zip
drive or maybe I burned it to a CD I'm
not sure but I was able to get my notes
off of the computer probably about 45
minutes before the thing just stopped
and never started up again so I got
really lucky it still was very frazzling
I lost a lot of files just before finals
in my second year of law school but
that's why I am very adamant to current
and future law students to always use
cloud services backup your files there's
a chance that you will never get them
back I mean laptops fail they're stolen
all the time you never know when your
computer is going to crash and you can
bet that it's probably going to happen
at the worst possible time so do
yourself a favor and backup your crucial
files and my final law school horror
story is that after three years of law
school over six semesters I graduated
with over a hundred and sixty thousand
dollars in debt yeah that's more than a
lot of people's houses cost that's three
BMWs worth of debt and that was over ten
years ago now law school tuition has
gone up even more so I really feel for
all the the current law students that
are out there who are racking up law
school debt it's it's crazy it's it's
everyone's personal Horror Story it took
me years to pay it off and it really
impacted my quality of life I don't
regret going to law school but all the
debt that you accumulate really does
build up
and man it's it's tough so those were
just a few of the horror stories that I
exper Sinhalese in law school if you
want to hear more stories about law
school check out this short playlist
that I put together that includes my
personal experiences with law school and
even better strategies on how to beat
law school once you get in and how to
get A's in law school also please
subscribe really appreciate it and I'll
see you in the next video